our las vegas aces they are back home
after winning the wnba championship look
at this they certainly got the royal
treatment flying back in last night reid
international tweeted this video of fire
trucks creating arches of water to
welcome the stars home and now las vegas
is celebrating its first major
professional title this morning and
getting ready to honor the ladies in
style
let's take a look first at the game
itself the aces maintained a narrow lead
throughout the game yesterday how about
raquana williams final two minutes three
baskets eight points when they needed
the most aces won by just seven points
final score 78-71
we caught up with the chance when they
returned home early this morning
we'll probably take some time away from
the team to realize
how special it was
how special this group was
you know and we probably won't ever have
this group will never be together again
we appreciate what we have great
coaching staff
great
management upper management like it was
just great from top to bottom oh it
feels really good you know my first year
in the league you know and playing
behind some dogs you know my first year
got a ring
it's time to turn up in vegas we lit
there we go belle even had a little
celebration there with our very own
kevin martin i like the dance moves
ladies
las vegas is going to celebrate the aces
down on the strip tomorrow night 5 30
p.m starts at the parade at caesars
palace which will end in front of the
bellagio fountain with the players it is
free and it is open to the public so get
out there and celebrate our ladies